Rose some insects and partake in a
little kidnapping this is an episode
that would make even Freddy Krueger
blush welcome to my world [__] hey for
Emily we got quite the episode for you
this week lots to talk about as always
this is not a recap of the show but an
in-depth look at some of the biggest
mysteries theories and clues as always
I've left time stamps in the description
below so you can see all the topics I'll
be covering now get ready the sun's
about to go down I actually wanted to
start off with the ending of last
episode and an apology for whatever
reason the version I got did not have
the final VFX of this ghost so while you
guys saw this I saw this that's a big
thing to miss for a guy who breaks down
this show fortunately you're not missing
too much since we find out in this
episode that it was all a dream so this
ghost which seems to be wearing a top
that looks a lot like Fatima's makes
sense because dreams often pull elements
of our real life into them and we know
that Elgin had been hanging out with
Fatima a lot now this leads into the
beginning of episode 8 in Kenny's dream
right off the bat we can tell something
is off because the phones in town do not
work yet Kenny's Rings he picks it up to
hear a cryptic rhyme stating they touch
they break they steal no one here is
free here they come they come for three
unless you stop the Melody I actually
want to start backwards here as I think
it'll give us a clearer picture of
what's going on the last line reads
unless you stop the melody a reference
to the ballerina music box then they
come for three currently there have been
four people who have had a music box
dream Boyd Marielle Kenny and Elgin Boyd
however transferred his blood over which
seems to have stopped these dreams
leaving Marielle Kenny and Elgin as the
three that they are coming for but who
are they all we know about them comes
from Martin who says they're worse than
the monsters roaming about town so we
have a haven't seen these guys yet but
it looks like they need three people to
get chained up in those ruins that Boyd
found in episode 2. since Martin and the
other two corpses are now dead this ties
into the line no one here is free a
reference to the chained bodies into the
broader population of the town perhaps
this is why the weather is changing
these three bodies had kept the town in
a Perpetual state of Summer but with
them now dead it's causing a lot of
change change which Victor says is not
good and finally they touch they break
they steal this could be a reference to
Mariel Kenny and Elgin who have all done
at least one of these things Marielle
stole the morphine Kenny broke Sarah's
ornament and Elgin touched Sarah not
physically but emotionally he cheered
her up when no one in town wanted to be
near her and even stole food for her so
it seems these three people possess one
if not all three of these traits
touching breaking stealing we learn from
Martin in episode 2 that he got caught
while going through through one of the
far away trees he says quote that's when
they get you so it's possible whoever
wants to capture these guys will be
putting more and more pressure on them
to escape via one of these trees where
they'll then be captured just like Boyd
was at the end of season one so this
rhyme comes during a dream dreams which
several of our characters have
experienced but what makes these dreams
even creepier is how they seep into the
real world when Elgin awakes from his
drowning dream real water comes out of
his mouth when Kenny awakens from his
dream he has a burn mark on his arm from
the cicada that jumped out of the
Boiling Pot of water if these dreams get
worse and worse it could get to the
point where these guys stop sleeping
perhaps even go mad and take drastic
measures to escape such as taking a far
away tree which is exactly what they
want them to do now it's also possible
that these dreams are Clues when Boyd
was haunted by the ballerina she showed
her arm almost as if wanting him to know
that his blood was the key to killing
smiley Kenny is haunted by the insects
the same insects that covered Smiley's
dead body perhaps indicating that
something about this body is important
aka the bile Elgin has a weird drowning
dream and we know he's had an odd
fascination with the pond and finally
Marielle has a dream where Smiley is
shot at is it just a coincidence then
that this episode is the first to
propose shooting the monsters with bile
covered bullets and just a quick
reminder before we get into more
theories if you like these types of
videos be sure to like And subscribe
every little bit helps the channel out
Jim continues to push the theory that
this town is all part of some experiment
and now that he's teamed up with Randall
things really start to get out of hand
last episode Randall theorized that if
this is indeed an experiment that it
would make sense that some of the town's
folk are in on it he even goes one step
further stating that no one has actually
ever died that those who seemingly died
were in on it and their bodies somehow
replaced I don't know it seems super
far-fetched even for me but put yourself
in Randall's shoes he just saw Donna
dispose of a body something that was
hidden from the rest of the town's folk
this is partly why he ties her up at the
end of the episode he and Donna have
been at each other's throats ever since
he arrived after all it was Donna who
kicked him out of colony house and put
him on that bus so he wants to
interrogate Donna for being one of those
townsfolk who is quote unquote in on it
but it could be far more sadistic than
that Randall might want to use Donna as
bait to lure the monsters and see a
real-life kill in person he and Jim did
mention that the next step would be to
observe the monsters and how they act
when no one is watching we also see the
next step in Jim and Randall's plan to
attach an antenna onto the Drone it
makes me think we might hear that voice
Jim heard at the end of season one again
if I see Jade bully Victor one more time
I swear to God speaking of which Jade
suggests that this whole town runs on
chaos theory that even though some
things may seem random or chaotic there
are actually patterns in rules hiding
within them I gotta say Jade is on a
fast track to going into these caves and
finding out for himself just what the
hell is going on and I for one am all
for it now Jade is pissed at Victor
because they made a deal that if Jade
played his mother's song that Victor
would tell him everything about that
symbol but Jade learns that Victor left
out the fact that the symbol was also
seen in that cave Victor has been
keeping a lot from Jade but as we'll
find out he's been keeping a lot from
himself too purposely blocking off the
memory of his mother and sister I mean
up until this point we never even knew
he had a sister according to Victor he
his sister Eloise and mother Miranda
whose name we can see here in the
credits were to go home the night the
bad things happen but it seems
Christopher had other plans Victor was
supposed to protect his sister and hide
out in the cellar but Eloise ran after
her mother and he froze waking up in the
morning to find the entire town dead no
word yet if he ever found Eloise's body
super for weird is where Victor chose to
hide Eloise's drawings in the trunk of
Christopher's car why put your
apparently dead sisters drawings in the
trunk of a man's car who supposedly
murdered the entire town one shot that's
been on my mind is Jade looking at
Christopher's car in episode 5. I wonder
if he ever inspected it or bothered to
look in the trunk now there are some
interesting crayon drawings here yet
nothing quite revelatory we have sad
people on a bus someone shooting some
other people the Bottle Tree and Civil
War soldiers we can infer then that
Eloise had seen the Civil War soldiers
that Jay did in season one the most
important drawing however is that of the
lighthouse the one we saw in the season
1 finale according to Victor that's
where his mother went the night the bad
things happened to save the children
locked in the tower and who happens to
be haunted by children well Tabitha and
who also happened to have a dream in
season 1 where she climbs up a
lighthouse Tower Tabitha a tower
littered with children's toys these kids
are yearning for her to help them and
the fact they Claw at her jacket a
jacket found in the second hand Barn
leads me to believe that jacket once
belonged to Victor's mother Tabitha's
bracelet the one she made for Jim and
magically found in the diner in season 1
episode 6 is the same bracelet we see
Miranda wearing something is guiding
Tabitha to that Lighthouse to help those
kids just like it guided Miranda decades
ago something is guiding Jade to obsess
over this symbol just like it guided
Christopher decades ago as Chaos Theory
would suggest this may all seem random
but is all part of a beautifully
orchestrated puzzle I think we can
officially say that the town has healing
properties with just how quickly Ellis
is healed I mean the guys should still
be bedridden after being brutally
stabbed in the chest Ellis is just about
to tell Boyd that Fatima is pregnant but
doesn't quite get to it with Fatima
stating that it was physically
impossible for her to get pregnant it's
possible the town has healed her too the
second last scene of the episode sees
that this man come out of his house
covered in blood accompanied with the
sound of cicadas this is Reggie who you
may recall seeing briefly in episode 5.
he and his partner and her sister have
taken over the house that once belonged
to Sarah so either something
Supernatural happened here or Sarah has
come back to take revenge giving her an
excuse to run off into the forest
remember she told Boyd that she doesn't
belong here and wants to go back out
there but how killing someone plays into
that remains to be seen maybe she
returned to pick up something and got in
a fight with the residents in there who
knows but now I turn it over to you what
are your big theories I want to hear
them in the comments below thanks for
watching be sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory
YT until next time remember welcome to
my world [__]
thank you